plant in the world today and I got to
tell you David this is the only thing
that is the best and largest in the
world outside of the state of Washington
and so I'm happy to be here and I am
thrilled to be here to think that these
folks are not only given us clean water
but cleaner air by reducing carbon
dioxide pollution what a great
achievement and they're creating enough
electricity this is an electricity
generating plant to power 7,500 homes
and they're doing it they're doing it
because they got great Union skilled
workers here these two folks that
understand that we can have good paint
jobs at the time we have clean energy
and I want to thank of Alexandria for
joining us her leadership has been
incredible I saw her in action I'll see
her in action again tomorrow New York
can we have a round of applause for her
and her generation but they're gonna
lead the clean energy
Thanks Alexandria I'm gonna talk about
my plan for a clean energy economy in a
moment but I have to get something off
my chest first and that is while I've
been on this run for the presidency I
have seen Americans who have been
damaged and injured and traumatized by
the abject failure of this White House
and this federal government to protect
them from the scourge of the climate
crisis I've looked into the eyes of
Marshall Moss a woman in Seminole
Springs California in a community of
about a hundred mobile homes that was
leveled because of the Woolsey fire and
we know our fires are going to double in
the next decades because of carbon
pollution and when you look into her
eyes and you realize that she has no one
protecting her in Washington DC it just
makes your blood boil yesterday I was in
Davenport Iowa I met a woman named
Regina haddock Regina is a courageous
leader in her community she started a
program called Dress for Success it
helps women who've kind of been down on
their luck a lot of single mothers get
clothing so when they go out for a job
interview they can feel proud of
themselves and a flood this Titanic
flood that has swept the Midwest has now
ruined this nonprofit when you look at
Regina who has been such a leader in her
community and understand that her dreams
now have put on on hold and not have
helped for Washington DC that makes my
blood boil it is time for the people of
fire and flood to have a president who
will stand up and protect them from the
ravages of climate change in this
climate crisis and I'm going to do
everything I can to make sure Americans
have that and a plan to get that job
done so today I'm announcing my plan for
the evergreen economy a plan to put 8
million Americans to work and not just
any job but good-paying jobs across the
United States of America and I'm proud
to offer it to the American people this
plan is built on four principles number
one it is built on the principle that
Americans always invent the future we
are never shackled to the past we are
never shackled to the technologies of
centuries ago we always invent the
future because it is in our nature to
invent to create to build and that is
deep in the American breasts and I
harken back to what John F Kennedy said
at Rice University he said you know we
choose to go to the moon not because
it's easy and do the other things but
because it is hard because it organizes
and measures the best energies and
innovative talents of Americans and I'm
offering the ever
green economy plan to do that yet again
to call us forward to yet a great
national mission mission to invent yet a
brighter future for Americans the second
principle is pretty simple
we need a full complete 100%
mobilization of the United States
economy to defeat the climate crisis and
put eight million people to work look in
this case half measures are not good
enough we did not defeat just our half
of our enemies in a world war two
another existential threat to our future
we defeated all of them and while people
in Iowa are seeking high ground from the
floods this week we cannot have a middle
ground proposal to build a clean energy
future we need a full-throated robust
and complete mobilization of the United
States economy and I'm offering
Americans a plan to do just that and for
people who say those fearful people who
are pessimistic that we can't do this we
can't mobilize their economy look what
we did in the 1940s just think about
this in 1940 the US economy produced
exactly 77 jeans 77 four years later the
US economy had produced 640,000 jeeps to
defeat fascism if we can do that we can
build new high-tech measures across
their advanced manufacturing sector just
like we're doing at the blue Plains
clean water treatment plant in
Washington DC so we are offering a plan
that is both scientifically sound and
eken
you
we're just gonna build any old job we
need high-paying family wage jobs to
rebuild the middle class with a major
proponent of people who under understand
the power of unions like these two
skilled workers behind us to grow a new
economy here's what I believe we got to
restore the ability of people to be in a
union we've got to stop the employer
intimidation that has frustrated people
who want to join a union we got to
understand that
major reason that half the people in
America haven't had a raise for 40 years
is because we've had a decline in union
membership here's what I believe the
people who brought us the weekend are
gonna bring us the evergreen economy and
start wage growth again in the United
States of America I fundamentally
believe that and we know we can do that
because we have done it before
so we are embedding the union movement
we are embedding higher minimum wages
and we are moving forward with better
wages in this economy by the way Donald
Trump says we got such a great economy
oh yeah
talk to half the United States workers
we haven't I haven't raised in 20 years
it's time for those folks to have a
raise they're producing more
productivity it's time to make sure that
they get a raise in America the fourth
principle that this is built on is the
reason we called it the evergreen
economy now it's obvious that it's an
evergreen economy because we need an
economy that's sustainable over the
decades and ours is not today because of
the climate crisis that our pollution is
causing but it's evergreen for another
reason it's evergreen because it is
built unknown successes in the Evergreen
State and that's Washington State if you
want to see what a clean energy economy
can look like come to my state the state
with the greatest GDP growth the fastest
wage growth clean energy jobs that are
growing
like it is nationally twice as fast as
the rest of the economy we have just
been named in Washington State the best
place to do business and the best place
to live by the US News World Report and
the best place to work by Oxfam and it
has not despite the fact that we're
building a clean energy economy it's
because we are building a clean energy
economy it's time for the fruits of a
clean energy economy that we are growing
in Washington State to be enjoyed by
Americans all across the country in the
evergreen economy plan we'll make sure
that that works so we're doing five
strategic things in this plan one were
igniting America's clean energy economy
with our 100% clean energy plan - we're
making the largest investments in
American infrastructure since we built
the interstate freeway system putting
Americans to work in every acute
community across the United States third
we're going to make sure that we build
advanced manufacturing jobs across the
United States by restoring the economic
competitiveness of our manufacturing
sector fourth we're making long overdue
investments in research and development
when tippling our investment in research
and development just like we did in
World War two just like we did when we
went to the moon we will do that today
again in the Evergreen economy and fifth
we'll make sure that these jobs are high
paying family waves jobs that's the
destiny it's the way to defeat income
inequality at the same time we are
defeating carbon pollution this is a job
we've got to get down to it so I want to
thank everybody who's involved in this
effort I believe it is a time for doing
big things I will tell you my plan is a
big bowl ambitious plan but it is
fitting for a big bold and ambitious
nation let's get this job done
thanks a million let's go rebuild the US
economy thanks a lot and with that
helping stand for some questions yes
well I'll just tell you what I believe
in I believe that we have to have a a
plan that is both scientifically sound
and economically viable and if you start
your assessment that you have to be
moderate or be in the middle ground
you're going to leave people under flood
seeking the high ground in Iowa which is
happening today and we need a
full-throated mobilization of the US
economy nothing else will be
satisfactory so what I've done I've said
that we need a hundred percent clean
energy and our electrical grid by 2035
I've said we have to be half on a call
by 2030 I hope others will join me I
hope Joe Biden will join me and when he
puts out a plan will say enslie's right
we need to do those things we need to
have clean cars by 2030 and I hope that
all the candidates will do that now so
far none of the candidates that follow
my leadership yet and I welcome them to
the party here because we got to get
going and I'm a proud Democrat and I
believe Democrats are optimistic
I believe we we stand for building a
middle class and I believe we don't
stand for half-measures
we need a full meal deal so that's the
offer I'm given to the American people
yeah
well I think that this is really look
the Obama administration did some great
things for us and we're gonna restore
the executive action that Trump has
tried to repeal by the way he has
largely failed because I sued him 21
times and I beat Donald Trump 21 times I
kind of like to celebrate that actually
so he has been unsuccessful because
they're so brain-dead these people could
not run a two-car funeral so he has been
unsuccessful repealing a lot of the
progress during the Obama era but we
have a new day we have a new scientific
assessment of what is necessary and I do
believe we have a magic moment it is a
it is a marriage of a moment of great
urgency there is no longer a line on a
graph it's paradise California burned to
the ground
it's Hamburg Iowa town find founded in
1858 that never flooded and was wiped
out by the floods that I visited a
couple months ago so now people are
seeing that with their own eyes how
urgent this problem is and at the same
time it is married by this explosion of
clean energy jobs look I was argued with
Meghan McCain on the view a few weeks
ago she was saying all you Democrats
going to take away people's cars what a
bunch of baloney I pointed out to her
though I'm driving it a new General
Motors all-electric bolt that the
governor of Washington is driving it's
made by the UAW members and worry on
Michigan it's the electric battery
manufacturers in Nevada it's the wind
turbines that Donald Trump says cause
cancer that are causing job growth all
across Iowa so we have this magic moment
of Americans realizing the urgency of
this climate crisis together with
realizing the new jobs that these
gentlemen represent was good highly
skilled union workers they only need one
thing they need an ignition point they
need the same type of leadership that
Kennedy gave us to go to the moon and
FDR did said we're going to defeat
fascism and that means you energize and
mobilize
the best energies and innovative talents
of America
and a fun given this noble honor I
intend to be that spark
America needs yes
well so far there is only one plan
offered by any candidate of any party
that will say we're going to eliminate
the use of coal which we have to do as a
scientific certainty there is only one
plan of any party that will say we have
to have clean electricity by 2035 and
that is a scientific certainty you know
people have tried to sort of suggest
where my plan is on the ideological
scale I actually think that's not the
right way to ask it I think we need to
ask us where does my plan fit on the
scientific scale as to whether we're
gonna rescue America from the ravages of
climate change and we are at the top of
that scale frankly other people said we
can kind of slide through this we can
kind of ignore the science it's just too
hard
that's the Donald Trump vision but
Donald Trump is an insecure small-minded
pessimist who doesn't believe that
Americans to do what we've done
historically in a technological basis
I'm the can-do candidate I'm the
optimist I'm the person who believe we
can build ourselves an innovator or self
over any challenge and that's where I
stand and we're going to avoid that
cliff
well first off I was concerned like most
everyone was the comments coming out of
this campaign but I will reserve
judgment until we see what Joe Biden
actually proposes and I will wait and
see if he can match the commitments that
I have made to the American people if he
does that I think it will be a great day
for a Democratic Party but to do so he's
going to have to up his game and say
categorically we cannot be shackled to
cold Jobs forever it will kill us on
health and economics and create a
national security crisis he's going to
have to say that we have to remove our
reliance on fossil fuels and our
electrical grid I have not seen to date
any suggestion that he can do that now
let me address why I think some people
have concern about this we know we have
to have a transition to a clean energy
economy and trend transitions involve
change and change sometimes have
challenges look we've got we've got
people across this country who've worked
in the coal industry who are dignified
hardworking Americans who deserve every
bit of support and respect of anybody
working in Silicon Valley or anyone else
in America their families your past
generations built the industrial might
of the United States and those families
in those communities deserve a
transition plan to help them that is why
what I've done in my plan is build on
the kind of things we've done in
Washington for our coal families so in
Centralia Washington where we are
transitioning off of our last coal-fired
plant we just didn't turn off the plant
not think about these people we've built
a transition plan of a 55 million dollar
plan to help with new jobs new community
investment new training and I have
fashioned this national proposal what we
do in Washington State I've proposed a
GI Bill you know think about it as the
GI Bill from
for coal workers I think of that as the
generational investment plan for coal
workers we need to guarantee their
pensions look their bosses are thinking
about going bankrupt and short cutting
the pensions for these families we got
to protect them by the way Donald Trump
has seen nothing but a continued
degradation of coal because of the price
of other cheaper forms of electricity I
proposed him not only to help with their
training and education but we got to get
him jobs it's not good enough to have
education you got to have jobs
Mostafa understands that and these got
to be jobs and help every family and
they got to be jobs not only in coal
country they've got to be in the first
victims of climate change which are
marginalized communities communities of
color so we can put the investments like
we did in Spartanburg South Carolina
that I visited a couple weeks ago the
Regenesis project which has now got
low-income housing with solar panels on
the roof because Harold Mitchell's led
that effort that's the kind of thing we
got to do so I think some people fear
that we can't address environmental
justice and economic growth at the same
time we're defeating climate change they
are wrong and if you want to know how
wrong they are
come see the state of Washington I'll
show you a great future for clean energy
jobs yes
you know I wish that the current
occupant of the White House had 25% of
the scientific acumen of Alexandria and
if he had 25% of his understanding of
physics and chemistry and basic science
he could not make the foolish statement
that can we can continue to pump out
unlimited amounts of carbon dioxide and
not destroy the planet as we know it the
people in her generation fully
understand that what is it that he
doesn't get you know I heard my friend
Bill Nye the other day do kind of an
interesting video that said you know why
don't you knuckleheads grow up and I
don't know any other way to describe
that because her generation and every
scientists in the United States never
studied this understand that if we
remain a prisoner to fossil fuels to the
mid-century we're not going to recognize
this beautiful country we will not have
agricultural land that is not flooded
routinely we will not have the air to
breathe in Seattle Washington on a
summer's day because of the forest fires
we will not have small communities in
the pine forests and aren't burnin down
we're not going to have more people
getting cancer and respiratory problems
because of the pollution and importantly
we won't have anything but a degraded
economy look people say how are we gonna
pay this I asked Donald Trump how are
you going to pay for paradise California
how are you gonna pay for the billion
and a half dollars of losses to our farm
community how are you gonna pay Miami
Beach we're having to raise up Main
Street a foot and a half that's the
question we got to be asking so this you
know 900 billion investment I make is
the cheap inexpensive way to save us
from this massive loss of the American
economy
so let's get alexandrina here and get
her a half hour Donald Trump I think
try to talk some sense into him until
then let's just get a new president okay
thanks a lot good luck